hello everybody what's going on welcome
to another Python tutorial video in this
video we're gonna be talking about how
to do real-time analysis in this video
we're gonna be doing this with sentiment
analysis as an example and we'll be
using this syntax API on tweets for this
and while I use the syntax API as an
example you can do this with any API or
you can even do it with your own custom
function so even though I'm using our
API you can do it with whatever you want
using an identical structure because
yeah I've had a lot of people ask me
about you know doing Twitter analysis
and they're almost always wanting to
they're coming from my you know Twitter
streaming tutorial they're saving it to
a CSV like I showed you guys how to do
and then they're wanting to do analysis
on that CSV and and this is kind of
problematic for a few reasons one is you
might as well streamline it with with
the actual stream and just do the
analysis as it comes in because either
way you're going to be using computing
time and either your pausing the the
Twitter stream and then doing the
analysis cuz it's gonna be really hard
to catch up anyways if you're constantly
streaming and then constantly trying to
do analysis on the stream because the
stream is actually pretty quick if you
have a decent internet connection so
it's kind of problematic for that reason
you might as well stay as efficient as
possible but also number two you're not
allowed to store tweets for more than 24
hours if you do you're violating the
Terms of Service that you accepted so
you can't do that anyway it's right so
with those two things in mind let's go
ahead and get started so first what we
want to do is we want to grab the
starting code from the previous Twitter
API tutorial video if you've not done
those tutorial videos especially the
first one then you can learn about it by
watching the video I'm gonna link you
guys to the sample code from those
videos if you want to learn about it
there's a video right above the sample
code you can watch that video if you
want to learn more about the API so
anyway go to that link and whenever you
do try to drag it over you should land
yourself on a page like this one so this
is the video you could watch that
for the twitter api and then here is the
sample code in case you've lost yours
rural condensed version you'll obviously
if you are still planning on not
watching the beginning video and you've
not done anything like this before
you'll obviously need your own consumer
key secret access token and access
secret or authentication token and
authentic i forget what they call it but
a token and a secret you're gonna need
your own and again if you want to figure
out how to get them and you don't know
how watch the video or go to DEFCON and
figure it out
so anyways otherwise for everyone that's
followed along just go ahead and copy
this code and paste it into an empty you
know script so the next thing that we
want to do now is we need to make a few
changes to incorporate what we're gonna
do next so again with with what we're
doing here I'm gonna use the sent decks
API you can use anyone's API or a custom
function if you're going to use a custom
function then you're not going to need
to import URL Lib or URL Lib too but
since I'm using an API I'm going to
import URL Lib so I'm gonna do that URL
Lib and then in the centex api for
anyone who is interested it's not a free
api it is a paid api and if you want to
know more about it just go to semtex
comm and there's a link in the nav bar
for the api so anyway that's that so
then the other thing we're going to need
at least if you're going to use
someone's api or our api you're gonna
need the auth so for me i'm gonna call
it sent dex off and just as a quick
aside for anybody who is using an api
and they have an auth don't make your
variable off because auth is used in twe
p even though you haven't defined
anything as well you define off down
here so it's going to it's gonna
conflict so so you can't do that right
so just make sure you're not conflicting
anything so for me I'm gonna call it
send X off because I have a sin tax auth
token here and I'm gonna leave that
blank for now and these you can try them
if you want but they don't work so
that's that so anyway and I'll fill
those in before we actually run it at
the
in fact let me go ahead and just make
the space here so just make sure you
import URL Lib if you're using someone's
off that requires URL encoding and then
make sure you add in whatever your auth
is for that API or if it's our API
adding that off there so now like I said
you won't have to use our API you can
use anyone's API or your own function so
in that case let's make a function so
what function do we want to pass the
tweets through because we're down here
this is where the tweet comes out and
data it's not the tweet they actually it
comes out as a the entire JSON output
we'll deal with that in a second but
what do we want to pass the tweet
through well we want to pass that
through a function so we're gonna say
define maybe make sure I didn't type
define already okay define and for me
I'm just gonna call it sentiment
analysis and this function is gonna take
one parameter and that's gonna be text
so this function is gonna do something
so the text that we pass through so in
this case we have to do URL encoding
with the syntax API and with most api's
you're going to need to use encoding if
you're sending through a text mostly for
the spaces right so you can't normally
you can't send in a string of text with
spaces it needs to be encoded and like
for example a space and with URL
encoding as a percent twenty right so
anyway I'm gonna say encoded text equals
URL Lib Kuo text and then I'm gonna do
the API underscore call equals and
that's going to be HTTP colon slash
slash syntax calm slash API slash
API dot PHP question mark for variable
text equals what then we append here
encoded text plus what was the auth so
and AH equals and then plus for me it's
index off but for you you know whatever
if you're using an API and obviously if
you're not using an API and you've
written your own custom function these
two lines would be you know you won't
even have those but then you know but it
let let's say you were writing your own
custom function let's say your function
is very basic and it returns analysis of
how long is the tweet so you would just
say you know x equals Len text right
that would be your function and then
what you're going to end up doing is I'm
going to delete this now and the output
from this API calls gonna be URL look
URL live dot URL open and it's gonna
open this API call and then it's gonna
read the result which is just a
numerical result but basically after
you've written your whole function like
this is my function right this is what's
gonna take the text and convert it to a
sentiment analysis numerical value right
so whatever your function is like maybe
you're counting the length maybe you're
just counting the number of times they
mention something that's what you do so
far and then at the end of the function
just have it return output whatever
whatever you want at that function to
return you just say that down here now
we'll come down to our listener and
since I made a bunch of space let me get
rid of this space I just want to have a
bunch of space from up there now and
obviously you don't have to do that the
only reason I'm doing that is so I can
edit in my you know all my little secret
codes here and run it in real time with
you guys
so anyway next what we want to do oops
too many spaces I'm just trying to
Center this a little bit so next what we
want to do is once we've once we've you
know put in our function write our
function that does whatever we want you
know Twitter analysis for now we come
down to the listener and here at least
for us you can use a JSON module I
always just kind of split it up I'm just
silly like that so let's say the tweet
equals data dot split and it's a split
function here and what we split it by is
it comes out text calling double quotes
and then close close a single quotation
and then we want the second part of that
or they first if element there and then
again we want to split again this time
we're splitting by double quote comma
quote source and then the zeroeth
element so it's the zero element so it's
basically this with everything and this
goes to the left and then this splits
and goes to the right if in case that's
confusing you can also use the JSON
module if you if you're comfortable with
that otherwise just copy exactly what I
did and this will return the tweet to
you so once we've done that we don't
need to print data anymore and so we've
got the tweet now what do we want to do
well we wanted to do some sort of
analysis on that tweet right and we made
this function that performs analysis on
the text that's passed through so we
would want to pass what the tweet right
through that function so the next thing
that we would do is we would say at
least for us we're doing sentiment
analysis so I'm gonna say sentiment
rating equals sentiment analysis so it's
calling this function and then what what
uh you know texts do I want to pass
through well I want to pass through
tweet right so I want to perform this
function on tweet so what it's going to
do is every tweet I pass through here is
gonna do the API it's gonna call the API
it's gonna output whatever the sentiment
reading is from our API return that
output and assign it to this variable
right here so we've done that now that's
really all we would all we need to do
the rest the rest is you know you save
it to a file or something like that or a
database so since the database is a
little more confusing I'm just gonna
save it to a file since there's less
steps involved so I'm gonna say now save
me and this is going to be the line that
we save is gonna equal tweet since we
want to have the tweet then we're gonna
do a plus and we're going to use a
double colon as a delimiter and the
reason we want to use a double colon
instead of something like a like a comma
is because people oftentimes are gonna
have a comma in their actual tweet so
you wouldn't want to use a delimiter as
a comma for that reason anyway so then
plus and then we want to have our
sentiment rating so it'll be the tweet
colon colon and the human colons right
the reason why we're using a double
colon is people use colons in their
tweets to write so anyways plus
sentiment rating and then plus since
we're saving it to a file we're just
gonna have a new line at the end of
everything so then we actually want to
save it to a file source
to say output equals open and I'm just
gonna save this to out loops output dot
CSV with the intention to append and
then output dot writes save me and
output dot closed you obviously don't
need to close there if you don't want to
sometimes when the operations are fast
enough I've had Python trip over itself
in theory it shown it with append but
you still can't be doing multiple writes
so sometimes it goes so quick
it probably won't with the Twitter
stream but I always just add that there
just for safety especially since we're
opening it every time anyways you might
as well just close it every time so
anyway we need to append or add that and
after that once you've done all that you
should have you should be complete right
so what I'm gonna go ahead and do now is
come back up here I'm gonna you know put
my consumer key in my sent text
authorization and we'll actually run
this we can see the output and then we
can also open up this output dot CSV
file so let me go ahead and append or
editing all my stuff real quick alright
so I've edited all my stuff you should
too if you haven't already and now let's
go ahead and run it so we'll run it and
for whatever reason it's taking a while
to connect I have like you know a bunch
of streams so maybe that's the issue or
are we not
oh we're not actually printing out the
tweet that's why so let me just run it
for a few minutes here sorry I thought I
was printing out to tweet I guess we
left that out so we were printing data
and then I deleted it and I should have
just changed it to tweet but it is
saving to our output file we really only
need to do it for a little bit so I'm
gonna go ahead and actually break this
for anyone that doesn't know to keyboard
interrupt just hit ctrl C and that will
break the script so now now that we've
done that let's check out the output
file so the output file should just be
in the same directory as your script so
here's my script here and so we can open
up the output so just add it with
notepad or whatever you've got and so
here is our output here let me condense
it so everything fits
so so as you can see here we've got the
lines here we've opened up space for
children 18 K displays have gathered I
don't know car crisis I'm not sure what
the car crisis is but negative 2 cent a
minute let's find one that's bad
collision involving one car one casualty
negative for obviously we didn't like
the search term was car so so obviously
a lot of car crashes this guy misses his
car here's a negative one [ __ ] up my
car screwed everything are [ __ ] up my
car screwed everything up for me damn
negative six yeah you know messing up
your car is not a good idea buddy
see is anybody actually positive about
their car couldn't get his car started
no I just don't really see anybody's
happy about their car it's very sad guys
let's be a zeros I see is there okay we
got a positive too but this 11-year old
boy who stopped traffic to rescue a dog
hit by a car so that was positive anyway
that pretty much covers it hopefully
that helps some of you guys out even
like I said even if you're not using the
sin tax API or even an API at all you
can just you can pass it through any
function here you know you don't have to
even use an API you could have the
function doing all of the sentiment
analysis within this function just
return whatever output you're looking
for and save it now naturally like I
said you you probably shouldn't be
saving the tweet to your [ __ ] is that
again you're not allowed to store tweets
for more than 24 hours so just keep that
in mind if you did follow follow along
you wouldn't you still you can't be
saving tweet for more than 24 hours so
just keep that in mind so you know like
for like some of the stuff that we do
sometimes we use like named entity
recognition so if we find the named
entity we'll save the named entity in
the sentiment with that named entity
and you know that's totally allowed and
so you can do stuff like that
but obviously again you just can't save
the full tweet but anyway so hopefully
you guys enjoyed hopefully that helps
some of you guys out that are trying to
figure out how you can perform analysis
in real time you just pass it through a
function so hopefully it was helpful for
you guys as always thanks for watching
thanks for all the support in the
subscriptions and until next time